بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله
واصحابه
اجمعين اما
بعد وصلنا في
فصل او في جزء من
فصل عقده الامام ابن القيم رحمه الله
تعالى في ترتيب هدي مع الكفار والمنافقين
من حين بعث الى ان لقي الله عز وجل ووصلنا
فيه الى سيرته مع
المنافقين
و هذه الفقرات من زاد المعاد مهمه جدا
وذلك ان النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم لما نصره الله تعالى على اعدائه في
غزوه
بدر فان كثيرا من اهل المدينه ومن حول
المدينه دخلوا في الاسلام
تقيه ودخلوا في الاسلام
ظاهرا وقلوبهم
لم تتقبل الاسلام فهم بايعوا النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم
وشهدوا له ظاهرا وكفروا به
باطنا وما زال الحقد
و السم يتغلغل في قلوبهم تجاه النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم واصحابه
والمسلمين وهؤلاء
امر الله سبحانه وتعالى بالكف
عنهم وامر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بان
يقبل منهم الظاهر وان
يكل سرهم وما في قلوبهم الى الله سبحانه
وتعالى
والمنافقون كانوا في عهد النبي صلى الله
عليه
وسلم جماعه ليسوا بالكثير بعض الناس اذا
اذا قرات القران تجد من اوصاف المنافقين
وما فضح الله سبحانه وتعالى به في كتابه
المنافقين يتهيا للانسان انهم
كثيرون وفي
الحقيقه النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم يقول في حديث حذيفه عند الامام مسلم
ان
المنافقين في اصحابي وفي روايه في امتي 12
رجلا هذول ال 12 هذول رؤوس
المنافقين منهم
تابوا وتاب الله
عليهم وبقي
منهم
جماعه تسعه
توعدهم الله سبحانه وتعالى بالدرك الاسفل
من النار نسال الله
العافيه وذلك انهم يؤذون
المؤمنين
و يحدثون البلبله بينهم والله سبحانه
وتعالى يقول وفيكم سماعون
لهم او ومنكم سماعون
لهم والله سبحان وتعالى
يذكر انواعا من الناس في القران
منهم الذين كفروا
ومنهم اهل
الكتاب
ومنهم الذين في قلوبهم
مرض
ومنهم المنافقون ومنهم المؤمنون وهلم
جره ومنهم
المسلمون
ف هؤلاء
المنافقون شرهم
عظيم لذلك اطنب الله سبحانه وتعالى في
ذكرهم في القران وفي ذكر
اوصافهم وقال سبحانه
وتعالى ولتعرفنهم في لحن
القول ابرز صفات المنافقين الكذب
هذا ابرز صفات
النفاق
يكذبون ولهم صفات كثيره عددها ابن القيم
رحمه الله في غير هذا
الموضع ولا باس ان
نذكر طرفا من
ذلك زاد المعاد
‏gr ابن القيم
الله
those in قران as
hrit hoc what is that hoc in
qu
is a mae
‏h hoc
as out accep
isam صل الله عليه
وسلم re
isam these are
indiv when the الله عليه وسم was
[Silence]
‏the toce
they some
their some of their transaction some
their bus might less whatever it is
there many reas
‏to whatever best suited them at the
moment what best suited them at the
moment well they alle to the propet صل
الله عليه وسلم they wining
butan
ch quickly wh the wind blows
‏foundation they stand on stand
for for this reas these
indiv الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
‏indiv
anag to the propet الله عليه
وسلم
hr
to weaken the muslim hoc will continue
to
beil body
‏days
علس of
time there will be earthquakes in medina
at which point all of the hypocrites of
med will
be will be driven out they will leave
they will flee in terror and will be pur
believer in
medina finally ‏but this is very far in
the future it's very important to know
the descriptions of
hypocrisy hypocrisy is of different
types but main element is
deat the main tra of hypocrisy is dece
the main tra of the hypocrite is that is
constant
lying a lying t ‏someone who very quick
with fal very quick
with very good
at
but they are very technical people as
well الله سبحانه وتالى يستخفون من الناس
ولا يستخفون من الله
الله سبحانه
وتعالى cr te eyes they make sure that
technically they haven done anything
wrong
technically you can't really prove
anything and so in our modern days iser
to pass
ag pass agressive
‏an this is the main tra of the
hypocrites and they gave a lot of grief
to the prophet عليه ولم from his first
arrival passed عليه الص
والسلام الله سبحانه وتعالى
صلى الله عليه
وسلم te him how to
deal this tye
person الله سبحانه
وتالى سبحانه وتعالى و ف فين
القول schs
isam from and
that the way a person uses his t
the way person
speaks this says a lot about
a about a person
religious religiosity person
كان علماؤنا يقولون رحمهم الله اذا اردت
ان تنظر الى عقل الرجل
فانظر كيف يتصرف في
وقته كان مضياع للوقت
كان يعني الوقت عنده ليس له قيمه فهذا يدل
على خلل في
عقله وكانوا يقولون اذا اردت ان تنظر الى
الى دين الرجل فانظر الى لسانه كيف يتكلم
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ذكر هذا في غير
ما حديث جاء مثلا عند البخاري رحمه الله
في الادب المفرد ان النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم قال الا اخبركم بخياركم قالوا بلى يا
رسول الله قال الذين اذا رؤوا ذكر الله
الا اخبركم بش م قالوا بلى
قال المشاؤون
بالنميمه المفرقون بين
الاحبه الباغون البراء العنت يعني بحاولوا
يغلبوا الناس اللي ما بيستاهلوا هذه
الاذيه هذه هي صفات
المنافقين ووصفهم النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
بوصف يقتضي النظر الى اللسان كيف
يتكلمون والله تعالى يقول في لحن القول
طريقه الكلام قد يكذب الكذب ويزيد عليها
من الصدق وسبكها
بالصدق حتى يشتبه على المستمع اصادق هو ام
كاذب قد يؤذي لكن يؤذي بطريقه غير
مباشره وهذا لحقده على الاسلام لحقده على
المسلمين
والنفاق على
ضربين نفاق اكبر ونفاق اصغر فالنفاق
الاكبر هو نفاق المنافقين
الذي ذكره الله تعالى في القران في غالب
الايات وذلك في اصله اظهار الاسلام وابطان
الكفر واما النفاق الاصغر بعض العلماء
يعبر عنها يعبر عنه بالنفاق
العملي هو من كان له ايمان لكنه ضعيف
الايمان ورقيق الدين فله من صفات
المنافقين ما له وهذه
الصفات لا تصل الى حد الكفر ولكن ضعف
القلب ومرض القلب فمن اجل
ذلك يكون صاحب هذا النفاق نسال الله
العافيه له من صفات المنافقين ما له من
الكذب ونقض العهد
والخيانه وما شابه ذلك جاء في الحديث الذي
يعرفه كثير منا في صحيح الامام مسلم ايه
المنافق
ثلاث وفي روايه عند البخاري اربع من كن
فيه كان منافقا
خالصا ومن كانت في فيه خصله منهن كانت فيه
خصله من النفاق حتى
يدعها اذا حدث كذا واذا وعد اخلف واذا
اتمن
خان وفي روايه واذا عاهد غدر وفي زياده
عند مسلم ولو صام وصلى وزعم انه
مسلم هذا هو النفاق العملي لا يعني ان هذا
الانسان صاحب هذه الصفات ليس مسلما انه
كافر
ولكنه من اخوان المنافقين هذه الصفات تمس
بالايمان وهذه ابرز صفات المنافقين وقول
الله ولتعرفنهم في لحن القول هي هذه
الصفات التي ذكر الله سبحانه وتعالى ذكر
النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
والنفاق امره جلل وعظيم
حتى جاء عن بعض السلف انه لا يخافه الا
مؤمن ولا يامنه الا منافق يعني المؤمن
يخاف على نفسه
النفاق واما المنافق فهو لا يخاف على نفسي
النفاق امن من النفاق هذه الاوصاف لغيري
ليست
لي
ولذلك
فان امير المؤمنين عمر رضي الله تع تعالى
عنه انه خاف على نفسه هذه الصفات وكان
حذيفه رضي الله عنه معروف بين الصحابه
بكاتم سر رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم اذ
اعلمه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اسماء
المنافقين هؤلاء الاثني عشر اللي
ذكرناهم في بدايه الدرس
ف هو ما اخبر الصحابه بهم
وعمر رضي الله عنه استحلفه هل ذكره النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم فيهم فقال له حذيفه
كلمته الشهيره لا ولا ازكي بعدك
احدا اسال الله تعالى
العافيه القلب السليم الخالي من الامراض
هو القلب الذي يخاف يخاف من النفاق يخاف
من الكفر يخاف من رده يخاف من ان يحبط
عمله وهو لا يشعر والله سبحانه وتعالى هو
العظيم هو الجبار هو المتكبر هو الغني عن
جميع خلقه هو
الذي يلجا اليه جميع الخلق ويعمد اليه وهو
سبحانه لغني عن العالمين فالانسان يخاف
يخاف الا يقبله الله يخاف ان يرده الله
يخاف الا يفتح له الله سبحانه
وتعالى فمن هذا وجزء من الايمان وقد ذكر
هذه الروايه البخاري رحمه الله في كتاب
الايمان من صحيحه جزء من الايمان ان يخاف
ضده يخاف النفاق كما ان جزء من التوحيد ان
يخاف الانسان الشرك لذلك ابراهيم عليه
السلام يذكر لنا الله
تعالى دعاءه واجنبني وبني ان نعبد
الاصنام هو الذي كسر الاصنام وكان مضرب
المثل للتوحيد ومع ذلك بلغ وطعن في السن
وذا الدعاء بعد ان رزقه الله تعالى
ولديه اسحاق
و اسماعيل وكبر في السن وقد يكون تجاوز ال
100 عام وهو يدعو وجنبني وبني ان نعبد
الاصنام وكذلك المؤمن في شان النفاق فلا
بد للانسان ان يتعلم هذه
الصفات
و اذا كان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
ان المنافقين من اصحابي وفي روايه من امتي
المقصود من من تشبهوا
باصحابه 12ث رجلا هذه القله الق ليله وقد
ذكر ابو حاتم الرازي رحمه الله تعالى ان
الصحابه الذين حجوا مع رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم في حجه الوداع
او من الصحابه او المخضرمين كانوا اكثر من
100000 لكن مع ذلك هذا العدد
القليل هذا العدد القليل جعل كل هذا الشر
بين
المسلمين لذلك النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال ايس الشيطان ان يعبده المصلون في
جزيره العرب ولكن بالتحريش
بينهم تحريش بينهم ولذلك الله سبحانه
وتعالى
يقول واصلحوا ذات
بينكم هذه مهمه
وهذا امر مهم
وجلل لان
المسلمين النفاق يكون في اوساط صفوفهم ولا
بد لان الامه
العظيمه لابد ان يدخل فيهم من ليس منهم
يريد ان ينال معهم ويريد
ان يكون له الفتح مع فتحهم وان يكون له
المغنم مع مغنم
هذه مساله انتبه ل المسلم
ولذلك فان في سوره التوبه في سوره محمد في
سوره سور كثيره من القران سوره
البقره اطنب الله سبحانه وتعالى في ذكر
اوصاف المنافقين حتى
يحذره يحذرهم المسلمون
‏lot of us believe that hoc is
something it was at the beginning of
islam and you know over time everyone is
as they seem and this couldn't be
further from the truth
hypocrisy is probably one of the most
prominent
traits of modern society among
mankind because we live in a world of
fake everything ‏fake food fake comfor
fake happiness fake promes fake wishes
fake images everything around us is fake
even our food is
fake our reputations are mostly
fake and most of people words are
fake h
‏fr the the traits of cards which is hoc
now has a different name hpy now is
viewed as being
politic and being someone who very wity
very
smart this is the kind
person pric ‏with his hypocrisy he able
to wear many masks and many faces and
then we call this playing chess you know
play g
right this is never the tr of the musl
and as true isam becomes more and more
scar and
fake and
phony claims to righteousness become
more and more prevalent it will be
‏hoc d الله سبحانه وتالى قران
hr have sickness in their
hearts now in distinguishing between
these
two
are h
‏in
theirs
isam
alls conant looking
down
mus but out
صلى الله عليه
وسلم صحيح الامام
مسلم مثل
المنافق كمثل
الشاه
العائ تعير الى هؤلاء والى
هؤلاء يعني كشاه العائ الزائده
في جماعتين
من الغنم في
غنمات هنا وهنا وهذه بتيجي بتتقلب
بين هذا الجمع وهذا الجمع بين المسلمين
وبين
الكفار يقول الله تعالى الذين يتربصون بكم
فان كان لكم فتح من الله قالوا الم نكن
معكم وان كان للكافرين نصيب قالوا الم
نستحوذ عليكم ونمنعكم من
المؤمنين والجماعه يتلونون والنبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم
يقول وتجدون شر الناس ذا
الوجهين الذي يي هؤلاء بوجه وهؤلاء
بوجه في حديث عائشه في
الصحيح صلى الله عليه
وسلم ex
‏h
hr
sheep som
sheep joins this group
and joins this flock and what he is
referring to is that they play in a area
and they are prominent
and are
‏compl non great area in where with
whoever wins whatever is better for them
at the moment that's where they
are and as we mention allah سبحانه وعالى
us princi understand is
hr ate
is surf what is it how to disu ourselves
from ‏the hrit and to the hres from
those who
believe schar islam separate hoc into
two categories two main
categories they mention that hpy is
major and
minor or in some
terminologies maj and h
‏h
h
h ma
hed by disbelief in heart out belief
with
the and as for min hyr it
is hr
‏not traits
astion narration of the prophet عليه
وسلم he mention that the traits of the
hypocrites are three if he speaks he
lies and if he promises he breaks his
promise another narration in s
ال when he speaks he lies when he
promises he breaks his prom and when
he gives alle ‏he will prove treacherous
and if he has given an entrustment he
will be he will prove untrustworthy
usually when we see this we
imagine that
you know when we look at
these types
of narrations when we look at these
types of verses in
quran the companions and the tabin ‏and
most early generations most pure
generations of this our
fora they used to say that
hypocrisy is that is only feared by a
true
believer and it is only overlooked by a
true hypocrite what does that
mean who
‏hr he is afra that he has the tra of
hyr he is constantly taking inventory on
his actions and his
words this type of person is only doing
so because of true faith in
heart and as for those who feel so
comfortable hypocrisy this is nothing to
do with me i could never be a
hr you overl it they not afra this is
‏that could se into their character this
is one of the biggest signs of hypocrisy
a person not afraid that they one of
them if you really afraid of something
and if you're really part of something
you fear it's oppos that's how humans
are you can only love something
completely by hating its oppos you can
only embrace something completely by
denouncing oppos that's how it
work and so
ابن الق رح
الله is
h and he has a few chapters in some of
his writings dedicated to all the trait
hyr that are
through not necess all the
veres
alla h
‏tra
and you can
for ابن القيم رحمه الله
تعالى الله سبحانه وتالى
hs
body صحح ملم the propet صل الله عليه
وسلم tells
us the hypocrites from among my nation
are
12 it doesn't mean the
whole me is during his
life the true hypocrites those who
founded it those who all these veres of
theed
regarding guys
‏read those verses if you read sur which
is at least a third of sur is all about
hypocrisy and the hrit you read many of
chapters of the قران you start imag that
the hypocrites in the time of the
prophet الله عليه وسلم in dos even
because it such
important but they were actually very
very few because evil is
‏is
so poison is so
potent 12 is more than enough to cause
so much
trou
abouts
trou time صلى الله عليه
وسلم المنافقون وصفهم الله سبحانه وتعالى
بقوله اذا جاءك
المنافقون قالوا نشهد قالوا نشهد انك رسول
الله الله يعلم انك
لرسول الله يشهد ان المنافقين
لكاذبون يقول سبحانه وتعالى ولهم عذاب
اليم بما كانوا
يكذبون وفي راء
يكذبون فابرز اوصاف المنافقين يكذبون
بقلوبهم ويكذبون
بالسنتهم ويتمرن على
الكذب حتى ان احدهم ل يبعثه الله يوم
القيامه فياخذ في الكذب كما كان في الدنيا
بين يدي علام
الغيوب ويظن نفسه انه س يجادل الله سبحانه
وتعالى
وياتي بهذه وهذه ومن هنا وهناك وبلسانه
مجردا ينجو من عذاب الله ومن اذيه
المؤمنين من اذيه المسلمين ومن الوضع خلال
المسلمين وتفريق جمع المسلمين وايذاء
الرسل هؤلاء هم
المنافقون يقول ابن القيم رح رحمه الله
واما سيرته في
المنافقين فامر ان يقبل
علانيته يعني امر النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم امر امره
الله ان يقبل
علانيته ياتون
يحلفون يقسمون بالله ياتون بالزائد من
الكلام وه هم في الحقيقه جماعه جبناء
ويرمون المسلمين بدائه كما يقول الشاعر
رمتني بدائها
وانسلت وهم راجعون مع النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم من غزوه تبوك ماذا قالوا قالوا ما
عرفنا من قرائنا هؤلاء او اجبن عند اللقاء
واشبع بطونا
واكذب السنه من قرائنا هؤلاء يقصدون
الصحابه المنافق عبد الله ابن ابي
وجماعته الذين جعلوا الكذب
صنعه و مردوا على النفاق حتى كان يخفى
احدهم على رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم هؤلاء يرمون
الصحابه والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
بالجبن
و كثره الاكل وكثره الكذب نسال الله تعالى
العافيه
يصفون المسلمين
باوصاف
انفسهم وح
هؤلاء الله سبحانه وتعالى امر النبي النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم بقبول
علانيتهم ويجاه
بالحجه ويعرض
عنه
ويغلظ ويبلغ بالقول البليغ الى
نفوسهم ونهي ان صلي
عليهم اذا مات
احدهم منع النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم من
الصلاه
عليهم وان يقوم على قبورهم يعني بالدعاء
و ان يشهد جنائزهم
ودفنهم واخبر واخبر انه ان استغفر لهم او
لم يستغفر لهم فلن يغفر الله له
الله
اكبر نسال الله تعالى العافيه
حتى عم النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم ابو طالب
لما دعا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم له خفف
الله عنه
شيئا جاء في صحيح
مسلم
قال سئل عن عمه ابي طالب فقال هو في ضحضاح
من
النار ولولا دعائي لكان في الدرك الاسفل
النار
ف
هؤلاء من بغض الله سبحانه وتعالى لهم
وغضبه عليهم فانه تعالى لا يقبل استغفارا
لهم سواء استغفر لهم خير الناس
فانه لا يغفر الله سبحانه وتعالى
له وهؤلاء ابتداوا في عمليه الاذاء اذاء
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم من حين وصوله
الى المدينه والدافع الاكبر
لرؤسائهم
الحسد الحسد والغيره من النبي صلى الله
عليه
وسلم عبد الله بن ابي بن سلول
كان عظيم قومه في
المدينه وكانوا يكرمونه
جدا يعني الاوس والخزرج واهل المدينه
يكرمونه جدا ويقولون بقوله
ويصدرون عن
رايه فلما قدم النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم حس عبد الله بن
ابي ان التاج تقل عن راسه وانصرف الناس
عنه انصرفوا الى من الى رسول الله صلى
الله عليه
وسلم
ف تغلغل قلبه
عليه وكان يؤذيه ولا
يفرط في اي فرصه
ليؤذيك وسلم حتى اول ما وصل الى
المدينه كان راكبا عليه الصلاه والسلام
كما في صحيح البخاري على
بغلته وجاء على جمع
من الانصار والمهاجرين من المشركين ومن
المسلمين كانوا جالسين في جلسه
فجاء فماذا قال عبد الله بن ابي نحي عنا
غلتك هذه اذتنا شو هالريحه يعني شو
ه من هنا يبدا
بهذا وهكذا الكلام كلامهم هكذا ل ترد عليه
يرجع يقول مالك زعلان شو شو الدعوه
وكذا ويلف القضيه عليه وان حساس انت هيك
القصصه شي القصه كلها يريد ان ينال منه ما
استطاع الى ذلك
سبيلا استمر هذا
الامر حتى توفاه
الله وهو على ذلك نسال الله
العافيه وجاء عبد الله ولد عبد الله ابن
ابي بن سلول كان ولده من
الصحابه من المؤمنين فجاء يطلب من النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم شيئا يكفن به اباه
فاعطاه ثوبه
واراد ان يستغفر له فمنعه الله سبحانه
وتعالى من
ذلك تاتي قصته ان شاء الله
واصحابه فيما بعد نكتفي بهذا القدر والله
اعلم صلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله الله اكبر
الله اكبر